une femme a été victime de racisme alors
l'absence de rock dur action est assez
choquante regardez cette vidéo
moi je croyais que c'était un fake au
début l'avion n'a pas encore décollé de
quand une dispute éclate entre deux
passagers très vite les insultes
racistes fusent de la part de l'homme
près du hublot sous le choc
dell s'ils ne répondent pas c'est sa
fille qui tente de calmer l'homme sans
succès finalement c'est la femme
insultes et que le personnel navigant a
changé de place l'homme les a même
remercié lamentin alors mes skis je ne
veux pas prendre la place bien sûr le la
défense du personnel vigo vais peut-être
qu'ils se sont dit voilà ça s'il
débarque un jour du départ qu est ce
assez par ailleurs la compagnie a fait a
minima un petit tweet en disant en gros
on a laissé les coordonnées maintenant
c'est dans les amène dans les mains de
la justice savait s'en lave les mains
ses comptes 1 secondes alors ça c'est
devenu je vais vous dire pourquoi on
l'avait vu ça aussi avec une enseigne
aussi tu perds marché mais quoi ils
veulent pas en faire trop
parce qu'ils ont peur que ça crée trop
le buzz dont qui lui ont valu cher un
petit tweet est comme ça on a fait appel
au fait c'est grave mais là c'est très
grave j'ai d'autant qu'il ya un appel au
boycott qui est lancé extrêmement relayé
au niveau mondial de la compagnie c'est
vrai qu'elle a réagi très mollement et
sous la pression elle a commencé à
prendre la mesure l'ampleur du scandale
mais franchement c'est inadmissible le
personnel doit réagir la compagnie
derrière le foot dehors
il est normal de temps il est menacé de
poursuivre il n'avait pas encore des
coûts et non des mandats
vous êtes bien dans l'espace un truc
comme ça dans un avion normalement la
personne qui pose problème
bien sûr les policiers qui viennent le
chercher donc je comprends pas pourquoi
ça c'est pas parce que c'est un délit
non la gare sur jésus calme tu
cautionnes charlie c'est juste un délit
donc c'est ici plus que ce qu'on a mis
hors la loi
la compagnie a parlé à la presse nous
allons creuser cette affaire est un
comportement perturbateur ou abusive de
ce genre entraînera l'interdiction de
voyager pour ses passagers interdiction
de voyager le mec il a fait lagache est
d'abord la villa le voyage d'une meuf il
a fait n'a fait passer la mauvaise voie
de choquer pas que le voyage elle va
s'en rappeler le droit de voyager sur
ses comptes devraient être dans l'avion
zut je suis content des prêtres dans
l'avion parce que j'aurais peut-être
avec la sud qui dit la sale bâtard de
nain j'aurais peut-être mort du monstre
achats d'avions
et on peut pas boycotter bab ryanair
parce que c'est des ils sont malins cd
dévoile à bas prix si on pouvait
boycotter mais malheureusement il fondé
voilà ces locaux sont donc les gens ils
ont besoin de voyager en avion sûr je me
frotte les gens à témoin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça aurait été énorme dans l'avion